تمسك انقره باطلاق عمليه عسكريه ضد
الوحدات الكرديه في سوريا دفع موسكو الى
الاعلان عن اجتماع مرتقب في الاستانه بين
روسيا وتركيا وايران بشان سوريا هنا نتحدث
عن مصالحه او ربما التسويه تحاول روسيا
العمل عليها منذ سنوات بين حليفتها دمشق
وانقره التي ساندت المعارضه السوريه في
الحرب الاهليه الاسابيع الاخيره شهدت
اشارات صغيره اوليه على احراز تقدم طفيف
لكن هذا التقدم تعرض للتهديد بعد التوترات
التي اندلعت نهايه الاسبوع بين تركيا
واكراد سوريا الذين يسيطرون على جزء كبير
من شمال وشرق البلاد سنه تركيا ضربات جويه
على مواقع كرديه في سوريا والعراق واصابت
هذه الضربات مواقع للجيش السوري ادت الى
عدد من القتلى والجرحى سوريا تخشى من ان
تنفذ تركيا تحديداتها تقوم بتوغل بريه
جديدا في البلاد الامر الذي تعهدت ان
تتصدى له القوات الكرديه المدعومه من
الولايات المتحده وتتفق تركيا مع النظام
السوري في عدائه مال الاكراد السوريين لكن
التشارك في الخصومه لم يكن كافيا حتى الان
للتغلب على اسباب الخلاف الاخرى حيث تدين
دمشق سيطره انقره على مساحات شاسعه من
شمال سوريا على طول الحدود المشتركه منذ
العام 2016
وبحسب الخبراء سوريا تعتبر ما حدث عدوان
وهذا يؤثر على اي وساط ايرانيه او روسيه
قد تفتح الابواب المغلقه بين انقره ودمشق
اذا وجوده تركيا داخل سوريا يمثل عقبه
رئيسيه امام المصالحه بعد دمشق
[موسيقى]